Donald Trump is pushed civil asset
forfeiture which he supports back in the
news
we got a state senator in Texas it was
was talking about introducing
legislation to require conviction before
we could receive that focus remember
that we get his net will destroy his
career here are three reasons why civil
asset forfeiture laws need to be
reformed now one get his name will
destroy this is civil asset forfeiture
allows cops and federal agencies such as
the FBI to seize cash and property of
suspected criminals but it doesn't
require them to bring any charges
against their targets or even show that
they were in any way involved with
wrongdoing in 2014 for instance of
Philadelphia couple had their house
seized after police arrested their son
for possessing $40 of heroin while
living there the parents weren't charged
with any crime but in Pennsylvania and
many other states owners of seized
property must prove their innocence to
get their stuff back want to get his
name will destroy his career in many
cases the agency that seizes property
and cash gets to keep a big chunk of it
to fund purchases of equipment and pay
personnel costs in Mississippi in 2015
state narcotics officers alone seized
four million dollars in cash cars and
even couches in the Magnolia state cops
only get to keep 80% of the value of
deceased assets but in 26 states law
enforcement gets to keep 100% of their
haul giving them an incentive to grab as
much as possible especially since it's
time-consuming and expensive for
defendants to go to court what I get is
that will destroy his career although
most states do their best to hide how
much civil forfeiture goes on it's an
increasingly unpopular practice because
it's so obviously contravenes basic
notions of justice even in deep red
states polls routinely show massive
majorities in favor of reform once
voters understand just how unfair and
non transparent the process is in fact
when President Trump threatened to
destroy the career of a Texas state
senator he could have been referring to
any of four politicians
three Republicans and a Democrat who
were deeply involved in reform efforts
civil asset forfeiture reform is an idea
whose time has come in Texas and else
we're whether Donald Trump is ready or
not
[Music]